it's early morning in Qatar
but the work at the World Cup Turf and
tree nursery is reaching Fever Pitch
there's grass to be cut and watered and
turf to be delivered to the stadiums
what we did here we just like grab a
piece of land from the desert and we
convert it to this beautiful uh
land full of Patrice and the grass
cutter is perfect for The Cross by the
way because the grass needs sun
need water need fertilizers and we can
arrange all of this here
the turf is cut into long lengths first
it's then carefully rolled up onto a
tractor wrapped in mesh and finally the
precious bundles are placed carefully on
the back of a truck to be moved to the
stadium
the team here have the process so well
rehearsed they set a record for the
fastest Turf laying of a football pitch
by completing it in just 6 hours and 41
minutes
but just like the first Middle East
World Cup the grass here is unique
having to stand up to More Boots and
colder temperatures over a shorter
period with matches held over 29 days in
just eight stadiums with our design new
design of the stadiums it's more
compacted and higher so we had a
challenge that with this air-conditioned
stadiums so it's cooler than unusual by
generating a new uh kind of glass that
can survive during the summer and the
winter and with the extensive schedule
of games we get to know which species is
going to work more for the World Cup
it's not just Turf that they're growing
here at this Nursery there's also all of
these trees some of them have been saved
from sites around Qatar While others
have been donated by members of the
community
this is the place that we saved all the
trees from all around the Doha some of
the trees are very old here that's more
than 50 years old actually for in some
area or some trees we know even how much
we bought it or how much the person who
donated for us how much he paid for it
so I remember one of the stories that
one of the guys he was a cateres guy he
donated like his grandfather three and
he said like my grandfather he bought it
for two Rial in 1970. so for me this is
like their legacy and the history of the
of the of the stadiums an average mature
tree absorbs 21 kilos of carbon dioxide
a year the equivalent of 170 kilometer
journey in a petrol car Qatar is
planting more than 5 000 of them they'll
absorb greenhouse gases and local
pollution as they aim for a carbon
neutral event
as the saying goes the grass and the
country will be greener on the other
side of the World Cup
Joanna gajroska Al Jazeera Doha